decorations and of course they're going  to serve up festive drinks there on  spring mountain it's open through new  year's eve in the chinatown area  enchant opens at the las vegas ballpark  on friday another cool new thing coming  here to the valley a christmas light  maze ice skating trail not a rank but a  trail holiday treats santa claus tickets  start at 29 for adults 19 for children  again at the las vegas ballpark you can  check this out through january 2nd we  have a complete list of all the fun  events happening around southern nevada  at 8newsnow.com all you got to do is  search holiday events  rudolph christmas is not off and you're  going to lead my team  oh rudolph called in off the bench  tonight cbs kicks off the holiday season  as well we're going to be showing off  the timeless classic the og rudolph the  red-nosed reindeer it's tonight at 8  right here on channel 8.